[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi est
dit mais vincent vinel et un dunk les
siens de 20 ans depuis plus de deux mois
il est sous le feu des projecteurs il
participe à la sixième édition de the
voice mais il était choqué samedi au
berner aux clayes-sous-bois il allie
deux passions la photographie et
l'aviation depuis dix ans au françois
boiseau capture les paysages et reliefs
français il expose actuellement à la
mairie et à la médiathèque de wimereux
et le théâtre alphonse daudet présente
du 16 womé sa nouvelle création
parodiant la croisière s'amuse la pièce
rassemble professionnels et amateurs
il a fait sensation le 18 février
vincent vinel est un jeune chrétien de
20 ans il venait d'interpréter lose
yourself d'eminem c'était son audition à
l'aveuglent de l'émission musicale de
tf1 the voice le week-end dernier il
était en concert aux clayes-sous-bois
elle nicolas landry pour les images
[Musique]
pour les fans de l'émission difficile
aujourd'hui de dissocier vincent vinel
de lose yourself le 18 février il tente
l'aventuré voice et cartonne avec le
titre d' eminem laventure sauvé ça se
passe plutôt bien jusque là j'ai
l'impression
plein de bonnes rencontres des moments
musicaux c'est top
ça fait super plaisir d'avoir un coup de
projecteur sur soi et en même temps
voilà ça nous permet de nous exprimer de
pouvoir transmettre la passion de la
musique qui est je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir la transmettre avec
un maximum de personnes parce que la
musique c'est fait pour partager
mal voyant de naissance vincent vinel à
seulement la vingtaine et l'oreille
absolue
celui qu'on surnomme le héros de la gare
saint lazare est originaire des
clayes-sous-bois il était de retour dans
sa commune pour un showcase
[Musique]
il chante bien il est super gentil
vincent une voix extraordinaire il fait
passer des émotions
intense aussi bien premier point que
vous à moi même et à ma femme sa
simplicité son talon et puis plein
d'énergie il y en a un talent fou c'est
un chanteur et musicien depuis toujours
il dit que pour ça qu'il est tout petit
il vit que pour la musique mais je
m'attendais pas à ce que les gens
ressentent sa musique de cette manière
et soit aussi enthousiaste
du côté du télé crochet vincent continue
l'aventuré dans l'équipe du chanteur
mika samedi dernier s'est qualifiée pour
les directs
[Musique]
un rendez vous musical à ne pas manquer
emily loizeau et sur la scène du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
12 mai prochain la chanteuse et
compositrice franco-britannique explore
le répertoire d'une légende du rock lou
reed écoutez cet extrait
[Musique]
ce père louis st
plusieurs mois
[Musique]
les naturalistes seven font tout avec
leur bouche les voies les instruments
mais aussi les harmonies les new yorkais
seront sur la scène de la merise de
trappes le 13 mai ils réinterprètent les
standards américains écouter
[Musique]
le jeu
le
ah oui mais
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
des ex des photographies pardon qui
ressemblent à des peintures françois
boiseau captures depuis dix ans les
paysages et reliefs français embarqués
dans un avion il expose actuellement ses
clichés à la mairie et à la médiathèque
de villepreux
les images sont signés camille lambert
[Musique]
ça ressemble à s'y méprendre à des
tableaux pourtant le pinceau de françois
boiseau c'est son appareil depuis dix
ans il mêle ses deux passions la
photographie et l'aviation est donc en
faisant les deux mains ça fait faire des
photos de paysages de
le morceau de notre terre pour faire des
formes de tableau est arrivé à des
compositions qui soit agréable à
regarder donc qui sont ici pour être
partagé ce qui m'inspire c'est les lieux
où il ya des des formes
et des couleurs très spécifiques donc ça
peut être effectivement les bords de mer
ça peut être aussi les champs par
exemple en ce moment il ya les champs de
colza mais que jaune et le vert ça fait
des trucs assez incroyable
ça peut être aussi
les forêts des vues aériennes de la
france le bassin d'arcachon la baie de
somme où les salines de guérande ou le
regard cherche le moindre détail
je me suis branché là dessus parce que
je trouve qu'on arrive quand même à une
forme de pureté dans l'aude dans l'image
que je retrouve essentiellement dans la
nord la photo aérienne que je peux
retrouver ailleurs aussi évidemment mais
là dans la photo aérienne il ya toujours
au fur et à mesure que j'avance et que
j'en fais d'autres à chaque fois et se
créent de nouvelles images etc jamais
jamais terminé c'est ça aussi qui est
intéressant les clichés sont rassemblés
en mairie et à la médiathèque de
villepreux dix ans la tête dans les
nuages
à travers 120 photographies le capitaine
stubing doc gopher vie qui peut être
aurez vous reconnu les personnages de la
série télé la croisière s'amuse
elle était diffusée en france à partir
des années 80 et c'est cette série qui
donne le point de départ à la nouvelle
création du théâtre
alphonse daudet nous avons assisté à la
dernière répétition regarder les sons de
jouer bien de l'importance
c'est un voyage qui ne sera pas de tout
repos pour sa dernière création le
théâtre alphonse daudet prend la mer et
parodies la croisière s'amuse
la série américaine diffusée en france
dans les années 80 ce sont des histoires
qui s'entremêlent
donc il ya et ses prix ces prix au dans
le répertoire théâtral aussi bien on va
retrouver les personnages de labiche les
personnages de monsieur perrichon on va
retrouver également les personnages du
malade imaginaire de molière on va
retrouver un don juan de molière on va
retrouver les personnages de anouilh et
tout cela ça va être entre mêlée est
entrecoupé de chansons de danse pour
fermer
à l'orgueil e péniche ou de se vanter de
l'avoir sauvée et ainsi de rentrer dans
sa sphère ils sont quelque 838 une
croisière de ouf a nécessité sept mois
de répétitions sur scène 23 comédiens
professionnels et amateurs
on est encore plus investi dans un
spectacle où on a à la fois le regard
est à la fois on doit jouer ce qui est
des fois un petit peu troublant parce
que il faut bien ce qu'il faut savoir
il faut bien doser c'est à dire que je
me suis surprise à à écouter les autres
à voir comment comment il fonctionnait
quand on joue avec des professionnels
quand il nous explique quel ton prendre
quelle attitude prendre alors qu'eux ils
l'ont tout de suite dont il est plus
facile de s'identifier de reproduire ce
qu'ils font
une croisière de ouf mêle théâtre danse
et chanson une production originale à
découvrir à partir du 16 mai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya pas d
paris
et
une autre comédie musicale à découvrir
sur saint quentin en yvelines et c'est
l'histoire d'aladin ça se passe au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir le
dimanche 14 mai et c'est un spectacle à
voir dès 4 ans regarder
[Musique]
le marché
la mer
les filles
c'est un lieu exceptionnel qui ouvre ses
portes au public ce week-end le théâtre
du château de brousse est inaugurée en
1957 la comédie française d'y jouer des
pièces pour un public exceptionnel les
têtes couronnées européennes
le samedi 13 et le dimanche 14 mai c'est
la troupe du crâne qui jouera le fil à
la patte de feydeau
la troupe basée à connaît les mots repas
il est en résidence
on a l'honneur de réveiller un peu ce
théâtre endormi qui n'avait pas eu de
spectacle depuis des années donc c'est
un privilège un honneur et voilà donc du
coup il faut porter toute l'équipe pour
mener à bien le spectacle je pense que
c'est tout simplement une histoire
d'hommes
christophe et moi nous avons je pense
tous les deux beaucoup de passion
commune ce que je disais souvent je
pense qu'on est tous les deux aussi fou
et qu'on a tous les deux l'amour de
l'art français dollar à la française là
le théâtre la culture la peinture
pour le coup de coeur cinéma de la
semaine on se rend à saint cyr l'école
écoutez mary lynn pook des yeux d'elsa
le coup de coeur du cinéma les yeux
d'elsa c'est la soirée ciné rencontres
le vendredi 19 mai à 20h30 avec un débat
qui sera mené par l'association addes
autiste qui fait oeuvre de
sensibilisation sur le parcours et le
quotidien des jeunes autistes donc pour
cette soirée nous vous proposons le film
dernières nouvelles du cosmos de julie
bertucelli qu'un documentaire qui suit
la création d'une pièce de théâtre à
partir de textes poétiques ces textes
ont été écrits par baboo iec et baboo
iec c'est également une jeune femme de
30 ans hélène qui est autiste qui n'a
pas appris à lire ni à écrire qui ne
communiquent pas et qui écrit des textes
aux fulgurances poétiques tout à fait
étonnante donc julie bertucelli la fim
dans la création et dans son expression
et elle filme ce mystère et sa manière
d'être au monde en nous questionnant
nous en retour sur le mystère du langage
et du cerveau humain de manière très
générale
en réalité je suis télépathe et
iconoclaste donc pas besoin de te poser
des questions tu sais celle quand on a
en tête on avait besoin de temps pour
savoir qui était l'âme dans son identité
mais lnc les deux peut-être les a
entendus qui par des acteurs au théâtre
quel effet ça fait
le premier rendez vous se passe du côté
de voisins-le-bretonneux le centre
alfred de vigny vous propose une
conférence sur l'histoire de l'art la
conférence se concentrera sur auguste
rodin considéré comme l'un des pères de
la sculpture moderne
une exposition lui est en ce moment
consacré au grand palais à paris et le
jazz est à l'honneur à versailles du 10
au 17 mai c'est une semaine de concerts
qui ont lieu dans la cité royale
le programme est à retrouver sur le site
internet du festival
cette huile culture est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis et je vous dis un mercredi
prochain
[Musique]